[음악]
네 안녕하세요 괴산암입니다 제가
오늘은
목욕탕 건물을 리모델링 한 사례를 좀
보여드릴 겁니다 되게 허름한
목욕탕이었는데 이렇게 멋있게
리모델링한 사례입니다 그래서이 지금
리모델링 한 거는 저희 그 예전
영상에 건축 영상에 나왔던 이윤호
이사님이 리모델링한 건물이고요 이사님
이제 설계한 그 건물
앞에 현장에 와 있는데
진짜 깜짝 놀랐어요 이윤호 이사님이
원래 이제 또 본캐가 있으세요 21g
회사를 운영하고 있고 그 반려견
관련돼서 사업을 하고 있는데 역삼점에
우쭈쭈라고
명칭도 되게 좋은 거 같아요 우쭈쭈
여기 같은 경우에는 합정점을 오픈
하셨어요 만약에 반려견 키우시는 분
있으면 한번 검색해 보시면
정말 너무 체계적으로 잘 돼 있고
역삼동도
진짜 놀라울 정도로 내부적인 공간도
너무 잘 돼 있습니다 그래서 한번
검색해 보시면 좋을 것 같습니다
합정 정도 최근에 이제 오픈을 했는데
너무
깜짝 놀랬습니다 말도 안 되는 사우나
건물에서 어떻게 리모델링을 했는지
한번 들어가서 보도록 하시죠
거의 한 1년 된 거 같은데요
잠깐 나가서
우쭈쭈가 도대체 무슨 사업인지 한번
좀 간략하게 제가 이제 건축의
종사하고 건축을 계속
디자인에 관여하다 보니까 공간
사업이라는 거에 대해서
관심을 갖게 됐고요 공간 사업 자체가
어떻게 보면 우리 건축가들이 제일
잘할 수 있는 영역이기 때문에 그래서
자연스럽게 그런 생각을 갖게 되고
디벨롭을 하다 보니까 저희가
경기도 광주에 반려동물 관련 시설로
1호점을 냈었고요
그리고이 건물 자체 프로그램이
굉장히 독특해요
동물 전용의 장례식장이라는
프로그램인데요 한 지점이 좋은 반응을
얻으니까
확장할 수 있는 기회도 생기게 되고
그러다 보니 제가 그 설계 업무를
잠깐 중단을 하고 저희
회사 내부에 반려동물 공간 관련해서
기획하고 디자인하는 업무를 맡아서
하고 있습니다
투자도 받으시고
큰 기업에서 투자도 받으시고 저도
이제 계속 그 수익형 부동산 디자인을
하면서 많이
느꼈던 건데 이제 그 공간 안에 담을
수 있는 그 프로그램들의 스펙트럼이
정말 넓어지더라구요 예전에
정말 단순하게 뭐 사무실이나 판매
시설이라고 생각했던 것들이 이제는 뭐
1인 방송 스튜디오라든가
어떤 공유 주방이라든가 또 우리가
여태까지 경험하지 못했던 그
프로그램들이 한두 개씩 생기면서
그리고 또 우리 팬데믹 시대를
지나면서 굉장히 많은 그런 공간들이
많거든요
그중에 하나로 오늘 반려동물
관련 시설에는 네 어떤 것들이 있는지
한번 소개해 드릴 수 있을 것
같습니다
여기가 이제
오픈 전인데요 이렇게 미용공간이
있어요 아이들 욕조부터 해서 건조시설
드라이기
높낮이가 이렇게 그 왔다 갔다 조절이
되고요
미용이 끝나서 대기할 수 있는 대기
공간까지 마련이 되어 있습니다이
지아가 반려견들이
물놀이 할 수 있는 수공간이 있어요
수공간에서 수중 트레이너를 받고
올라와서 이렇게 건조도 할 수가
있고요 미용도 같이 할 수가 있습니다
와 이거 뭐야 지금은 이제 물을 다
빼놨어요
물을 채우면 수심이 한 1.5m까지
차요 이제 트레이너 분들하고 소형견
대형견까지도 충분히
물놀이 할 수 있는 공간이고요
관절이 이제 안 좋은 아이들은
받을 수 있는 거죠
지하다 보니까 이런 공조시설들도 잘
받쳐 놨고
무슨 어린이 수영장 같아요
똑같다고 보시면 돼요
음습하고 막 습기도 많은 공간이었어요
저런 전열 교환기
시스템이 필수였고요
냉난방기나 이런 것들도 잘 가동이
되고 수영장
물도
온수가 잘 나오게끔 우리 시스템
설비가 되어 있습니다 그리고
요게 이제 모니터를 둬서 1층
보호자들이 수영장 시설을 같이 볼 수
있게끔 유도를 하는 거죠 1층은
보시면은 아까 말씀드린 대로
리세션하고
판매 시설들
디테일 샵이 있어요 그래서 저 벽
자체에다가
타공판 제공을 썼거든요 그래서 뭐
물건 dp를 좀 자유롭게 할 수
있도록
기법을 사용을 했습니다
이거 오피스에도 많이 달잖아요
오피스에도 많이 달잖아요 자석도
붙일 수 있고 이런 악세사리 부품들이
그런 것들을 사서 우리가 원하는 대로
베리에이션 조정할 수가 있는 거죠
그러면 이제 벽을 안 뚫어도 되니까
벽을 안 떨어져요
우쭈쭈 반려동물 건강검진센터 여기가
이제 아까 말씀드린 그 대한민국 최초
알려드리도록
[음악]
영업 준비 중인데요
먼저 그 보호자들이 건강검진
프로그램에 대해서 자세하게 상담을
받아야 돼요
들어오셔서 이렇게 상담 받으실 수
있게 공간이 마련돼 있고요 상담을
마치시면 보호자는 이제 출입을 못
하시고 우리 반려견만 데리고이 안에
검진센터로 들어가서
피검사라든가 그 다음에
어떤 엑스레이 검사 초음파 검사 이런
것들을 다 순차적으로 받을 수가
있습니다 아 그래요
야 이거 뭐
아무래도
시설 청결도가 되게 중요하기 때문에
그런 청소라든가 이런 거 굉장히
깔끔히 하고 있고요
인테리어도
깔끔한 색상으로
청결한 이미지를 강조하려고 했어요
그래서 우리 초음파
기계 설비 모습이고요 이런 우리 전문
그 수의사님들이 이렇게 반려견들 잘
건강검진 해주고 있습니다 그
동네 병원보다도
아무래도 이제 저희 1호점 2호점
그리고 지점 확장 계획에 있어서
요런 그 건강관리까지 해주는 것을
어떤 저희 특장점으로 봤구요 저희
이런 관광지를 받으시면 저희 멤버십을
이용하시는데도 다 같이 활용하실 수
있는
부분이 있습니다
카펫을 그냥 일부러 하신 거죠 아이들
미끄러운 방지 때문에 저희가 요런
카펫을 했고요 그리고 카펫이 약간의
그 쿠션감도 있어요 그래서 우리 계단
바닥재들이 다 딱딱하잖아요 일부러 좀
부드러운 소재로 마감을
했습니다이 지금 바닥 마감재도
레진 몰탈이라고 해서
방수하고 미끄럼 방지할 때 많이
사용하는 재료거든요 이런 재료들도
같이 구비를 해놨습니다
건물이
기존에 대중탕 그 목욕탕
건물이었어가지고
창문이 없는 건물이에요 그래서 일종의
그 먹방이라고 하죠
창문이 없는 방을 그래서 답답할 수도
있기 때문에 일부러 이런
식물 인테리어를 좀 통해서 반 외부
같은 공간을 좀 연출하려고 했어요
여기가 지금 우리 건물의 중심
공간이거든요
[음악]
간접조명으로
약간 채광 같은 느낌을 내려고
작은 마당을 마련을 해놨습니다
하나를 보시면은
우리 보통 그 반려견 호텔 그러면
견사 같이
답답한 그런 우리를 많이 만드는
편인데 저희는 아이들 하나하나 이제
방 같은 개념으로 봤어요 그래서
이렇게 층고도 높이고
편안한 조명하고
각자 개인 물품을
구비할 수 있는
붙박이장까지 마련을 하고
여기는 다른 데에 비해서 조도가
낮아요 아이들이 좀 휴식을 하는
공간이기 때문에
요게 가둬놓고 못 나오게 하는 공간이
아니라
정말
잠을 자고
뛰어놀다가 휴식을 취하는 공간이겠지
우리가
요즘 공간 임대업이라고 하잖아요
그래서 이것도
임대업이 되겠군요 이것도 이제 특수한
어떤 시설이긴 하지만 공간을
임대한다는 그런 뜻에서는 같은
프로그램을 볼 수가 있는 거지 그런
시설이 반려동물 쪽에서도
필요한 거고요 집에서 할 수 없는
프로그램을 밖으로 끄집어내서 우리가
이제 사업화 할 수 있는 거죠
반려동물
장례식장 같은게 그 어디에서도 할 수
없는 행위를 그곳에서 하는 거잖아요
추모공간도 일종의 공간을 임대해주는
사업이라고 볼 수가 있습니다
쭉 이렇게
저기서부터가 아이들 놀 수 있는 그
운동장이에요
저 밑으로 통해서 보시면은 보실 수가
있습니다 아 그러네요 엄청
계단실 디자인 고민이 많았어요 아
이거 진짜 잘해놨어요 여기가
엘리베이터가 없는 건물이다 보니까
계단 디자인에 집중을 좀 많이
했거든요 어떻게 하면 좀 재밌게
편안하게 안전하게 올라갈까
그러면서도 좀 공간감을 느낄 수
있어야 되니까
계단실을 보통 이렇게 다 벽으로 막혀
있잖아요 맞아요 다 털어버리고 유리랑
투명한
어떤 그 조명의 공간으로 만들어 놓은
거죠
[음악]
우리가 그 반려견 교육사업이라고 하면
보통 반려견 훈련을 받는 거를 생각을
많이 하잖아요
근데 사실은 이제 보호자들도 교육을
많이 받으셔야 돼요 보호자도 교육이요
그래서 이제 3층은 그 반려견
보호자들이 교육을 받을 수 있는
아이들은 이런 거는 너무 좋죠
말도 안 된다 이건 진짜
아무래도 건축주 분들께서도
리모델링 하거나 이제 본인의
건물이라고 생각하시고 디자인 하실 때
되게 좀 주의하셔야 될 부분이
본인이 하고 싶으신 그런 취향에
분명히 있으시잖아요
근데 이게 본인의 주택이라든가 이런
것들은 얼마든지
원하시는 대로 해도
문제가 없지만 이런 수익형 부동산
이런 사업을 하는 건물은
결국에는 그 소비자들 트렌드도 알아야
되고 여기서 운영할 사람들의 특징도
면밀히 파악을 해야 되고 그런 것도
이제 좀 보편 타당한
스타일로 이제 리모델링이 돼야 되는데
그런데 있어서 어떻게 보면 그런
리모델링을 하시기 전에 저희 같은 그
임차인하고 먼저 같이
연결이 되는
굉장히 시너지가 좋을 것 같아요
그런게 되게
비용적으로나이 사업을 같이 공유해서
한다는
공사비를 대주시면 저희가 수익을
쉐어를 해드릴 수 있어요 요즘 그거
많이 해요 그래서 그런 식으로 좀
다양한 경로로 협의를 하면
훨씬 더 좀 다채롭게 사업이
활성화되지 않을까 건물의
어떤 가치를 올리는 면에서도 이렇게
어떤 브랜드가 하나가 입점을 해서
여러
지점 중에 하나가 되게 되면 훨씬 더
그 가치도 높아질 것 같고요
오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요 그래서
앞으로 좀 더 뵙기 어려워질 것도
같이 너무 몇번이어가지고 이게
합정하고 이제 다음에 또 지점이
생기면은 그때 한번 또 말씀해 주시면
제가
촬영을 하도록 하겠습니다
네스 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 다음
시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다